hamlet has been having delusions
hallucinations anhedonia lack of
motivation and poor speech he sees
ghosts and all denmark thinks he's crazy
but what is actually happening you
being the smarty pants that you are
diagnosed him with schizophrenia
most people believe that schizophrenia
is caused by abnormal dopamine activity
in the brain
dopamine is a neurotransmitter that is
expressed in the central nervous system
and regulates things like motivation
cognition emotions and the reward system
dopamine binds to dopamine receptors
which are g-protein-coupled receptors
that are located in the postsynaptic
membrane this changes the structure of
the receptor which can then activate a
nearby g protein by exchanging the
bounded gdp molecule for a gtp molecule
once activated the g protein splits with
its alpha subunit and the bound gtp
moving to bind to adenylyl cyclase
the adenylyl cyclase is then activated
producing cyclic amp
and spreading the signal throughout the
cell schizophrenic patients have a
neural activity at dopamine receptors
specifically d2 receptors with increased
dopamine levels in the mesolimbic area
of the brain
and decreased levels in the prefrontal
cortex increased levels cause positive
symptoms like hallucinations and
delusions while decreased levels cause
negative and cognitive symptoms
like lack of motivation and decreased
levels of emotional expression because
of the true cause of schizophrenia is
unclear treatment aims to reduce
symptoms instead
antipsychotic drugs specifically
risperidone binds to neurotransmitters
like the d2 receptor
and inhibits dopamine from binding which
alleviates positive negative and
cognitive symptoms
however treatment doesn't always work
some are unresponsive to medication
most drugs only reduce positive symptoms
not negative or cognitive ones
and antipsychotics have severe side
effects and in general schizophrenia
prevents people from leading normal
lives
they can't form relationships or get an
education or job and need constant
support to manage symptoms
therefore social awareness is needed to
help those with schizophrenia
understanding schizophrenia can support
patients especially ones with suicidal
or unhealthy lives
decrease re-hospitalization and
stigmatization monitor treatments and
bring them closer to normal life
and there we go how can you help hamlet
and others like him
you